[Aplausos]
el camino de donald trump hacia la
recuperación del cob y 19 ha sido tan
divisorio como su política renunciando a
la cuarentena a la que se supone que
está sometido mientras aún es contagioso
el domingo el presidente portando
mascarilla se sube a un automóvil para
saludar a sus seguidores algo que ha
suscitado la preocupación de los
expertos médicos que se preocupan por la
seguridad de las demás personas dentro
del vehículo minutos antes de su
improvisada salida publicó un vídeo en
su página de twitter con los nuevos
avances de la enfermedad
así que ha sido un viaje muy interesante
he aprendido mucho sobre el cob y lo
aprendí yendo realmente a la escuela
esta es la verdadera escuela esta no es
la escuela de leamos un libro y lo
entiendo lo entiendo y es una cosa muy
interesante y voy a dejar que lo sepas
una visita que ha sido considerada de
responsabilidad asombrosa según un
médico del walter reed cada persona en
el vehículo durante ese paseo
presidencial completamente necesario
ahora tiene que estar en cuarentena
durante 14 días pueden enfermarse pueden
morir por el teatro político mandados
por son a poner en riesgo sus vidas por
el teatro esto es una locura según los
médicos el presidente de eeuu está
actualmente en un tratamiento de cinco
días con el antiviral rem de civil y un
cóctel de vitaminas sus niveles
fluctuantes de oxígeno también han sido
tratados con un esteroide de tecsa meta
zona algo que la oms es sólo recomienda
en casos graves de la enfermedad
a medida que trump se recupera las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre están cada
vez más cerca con el presidente fuera de
la campaña indefinidamente sus aliados
de alto perfil están listos para asumir
el control de la campaña
los próximos días incluyendo al
vicepresidente max payne y los hijos de
trump eric y donald júnior